quel enchaînement donc on se retrouve
maintenant avec alain chamfort qui est
notre invité ce soir dans un cocktail
votre premier disque 772 là c'est ça il
y avait eu des débuts ça voulait
raconter dans télérama d'il ya quelques
jours il ya eu des débuts nous les a mis
à mal les barrières au nouveau quelque
chose
nous sommes très très comme ça le voyeur
finalement oui ou lecteurs vous avez
débuté derrière la barrière qui a débuté
mardi mais pas vous avez des musiciens
d'alain barrière qui vous n'êtes pas
voulu continuer parce que les fin de
concert c'était bonjour la bière et la
belote et ça ça vous convenant message
center un peu mal d'imagés tcd sujet
parce que il ya une interprétation un
peu personnel a perdu journalistes à la
barrière et peut prendre contre lui
alors je vais vous dire ce n'était pas
ce qui n'était pas visé du tout il est
important plus est elle dit dans
l'article je sais plus son déclin enfin
troisième échange n'est pas la peine
voilà c'est pour ça j'espère qu'ils la
poche mais je crois que vous avez été
aussi derrière dutronc oui c'est ça j'ai
commencé à part accompagné jacques
dutronc pendant un an ou deux c'est un
an 60 7 66 67
et puis j'étais donc j'avais une
formation de musicien
et puis après j'ai accompagné alain
barrière j'ai commencé à faire des
chansons dont constructo de françois je
vais présenter les chansons vient
d'enregistrer quelques unes et puis un
jour il m'a demandé les chantiers
adjointe andrée compter la même chose
que ce que ça saoule et jeudi vous avez
été d'ailleurs beaucoup j'en faisais
travailler avec beaucoup de gens il ya
eu aussi gainsbourg un petit peu plus
tard récemment vous êtes parti en inde
tout seul parti avec un synthétiseur
commun à tous c'est toujours un peu la
presse qui qui qui enfin qui enjolivent
peut-être r d histoire vous avez été
aussi fait quelque chose par récemment
avec touré kunda vous aimez bien ce côté
msf musique sans frontières oui façon
qu'on le veuille ou non maintenant c'est
un petit peu le kg durant soit les
influences de toutes les musiques qui
viennent de toutes les géographies
possible et donc c'est important
quelquefois j'aime bien aller aux
devants quand le devienne pas à moi
directement alors je crois que au départ
vous vous intéressiez beaucoup plus
d'ailleurs à la musique qu'aux paroles
des chansons c'est ça vous y attachez
voilée parce que quand on est petit
quand on a une formation de musiciens on
est à l'oreille qui s'habituent à
écouter la musique est réceptif à la
musique
et puis et puis les textes je veux dire
j'ai j'avais pas une attention
particulière pour les tec je les
écoutais pas donc souvent je connaissais
beaucoup de chansons de l'affreux
donnait tout mais jamais jamais écouté
ce qu'il était dit dans et au début que
deux au moment où j'ai commencé à faire
des chansons se portait très peu
d'attention aux textes vraiment
l'impression que ça n'existait pas quoi
bon pied videmment j'ai réagi après
est-ce que le travail justement avec
gainsbourg a été peut-être un déclic à
ce moment là avant lui déjà quand même
mais j'ai quand même quand on regarde
les textes il ya juste là j'apprends
beaucoup joué en équipe avec des images
qu'on vous colle aussi on dit tiens
c'est un élégant alain chamfort siens
dandy là vous dites dans le jeu laisse
couler ce votre dernier album je joue
les dandy's oui disent et c'est
passionnant vous allez jouer un petit
peu avec vous même sur l'image qu'on
vous colle c'est à dire je suis pas si
on colle des images des images elles se
font un peu d'elle même je dis bon après
les termes de dandysme et d'autres c'est
ça c'est des accroches journalistique
mais enfin bon je vais te raconter un
peu
à son avis y est enfin mais c'est pas
non plus quelque chose qui concentre
toutes mes forces que vous avez surtout
pour votre dernier album vous avez
travaillé avec trois auteurs je crois
oui comment est-ce qu'on a ri je sais
pas faire passer à travers trois auteurs
les choses qu'on a envie de dire comment
est ce que ça se passe le travail comme
ça l'a 4 en fait oui mais oui absolument
mais c'est parce que je crois que ça
fonctionne par affinités dire moi je le
travaille qu'avec des gens avec qui je
me sens bien avec qui j'ai des choses à
partager
et un jour on décide de travailler mais
c'est surtout ce qui nous réunit c'est
celle de l'amitié où tout cas des
dégoûts en commun des choses et et puis
une fois qu'on a envie de travailler
vont nécessairement se trouve à avoir
envie de parler des mêmes choses et ces
trois personnalités face et trois
auteurs sont différents ils n'ont pas le
même âge etc mais ils ont vraiment une
même culture que vous appartenez même
génération malgré tout et finalement il
ya une espèce de d'unités dans le disque
on n'a pas vraiment l'impression que ça
a été écrit par les gens différents
parce que elle et on a tous le même
langage on parle d'eux mêmes choses et
on s'intéresse au même curiosité mais on
al'impression de la variété à beaucoup
bouger là ces dernières années
des gens comme vous avec des gens comme
notamment pour prendre les plus récents
et niagara qui étaient là les gens
d'ailleurs qui sont plus jeunes dans le
métier que vous oui mais qui vous
considèrent comme étant de leur famille
ça ça nous a frappés on n'a reçu niagara
ya pas très longtemps oui c'est vrai que
je me sens plus liés à ceux qui ont des
sensibilités que que celles qui étaient
des usagers de la chanson française
zavody faire quelque chose de léger de
fred d'aérien oui avec un peu de
distance le morceau bon